[Music]
Um yeah and brief introduction to Zapier
agents. Um I believe many of you know
what Zap year is. This automation
software a lot of boxes arrows
essentially about automation uh
automating your business processes. Um
agents is just well more agentic
alternative to Zapier. You describe what
you want. We propose you a bunch of
tools a trigger and you enable that and
hopefully we enable your we automate
your whole business processes. Um and a
key lesson that we have after those
those two years is that um building good
AI agents is hard and building good
platform to enable nontechnical people
to build AI agents is even harder.
That's because AI is nondeterministic.
But on top of that, your users are even
more nondeterministic. They are going to
use your products in a way that you
cannot imagine up front. So um if you
think that building agents is not that
hard, you probably have this kind of
picture in mind. Um you probably
stumbled upon this library called
blankchain. Um you pulled some examples
tutorial. Um you tweaked the prompt,
pulled a bunch of tools. you chatted
with this solution and they thought,
well, it's actually kind of working. All
right, so let's deploy it and let's
collect some profit. Um, turns out the
reality has a surprising amount of
detail and we believe that building
probabilistic software is a little bit
different than building traditional
software. Um, the initial prototype is
only a start and after you ship
something to your users, your
responsibility switches to building the
data flywheel. So once you start once
your user starts using your product uh
you need to collect the feedback you're
starting to understand the usage
patterns the failures so they can then
you can build more evolves build an
understanding of what's failing what are
the use cases um as you're building more
evils and burn features probably your
product is getting better so you're
getting more users and there are more
failures and you have to build more
features and on and on and on. So yeah,
it form it forms this data flywheel. But
starting with the first step.
Okay. Yeah. So starting from the
beginning, how do you start collecting
actionable feedback?
Backing up for just a second. The first
step is to make sure you're
instrumenting your code, right? Which
you probably already are doing. Whether
you're using brain trust or something
else, they all offer like an easy way to
get started like just tracing your
completion calls. And this is a good
start, but actually you also want to
make sure that you're recording much
more than that in your traces. You want
to record the tool calls, the errors
from those two calls, the pre and
postprocessing steps. That way, it will
be much easier to debug what went wrong
with the run.
And you also want to strive to make the
run repeatable for eval purposes. So,
for instance, if you log data in the
same shape as it appears in the runtime,
it makes it much easier to convert it to
an evo run later because you can just
prepopulate the inputs and expected
outputs directly from your trace for
free. And this is especially useful as
well for two calls because if your two
call produces any side effects, you
probably want to mock those in your
emails. So you get all that for free if
you're recording them in a trace.
Okay, great. So you've instrumented your
code and you started getting uh all this
raw data from your runs. Now it's time
to figure out what runs to actually pay
attention to. Um explicit user feedback
is feedback is really high signal. So
that's a good good place to start.
Unfortunately, not many people actually
click those classic thumbs up, thumbs up
and thumbs down buttons. So, you got to
work a bit harder for that feedback. And
in our experience, this works best when
you ask for the feedback in the right
context. So, you can be a little bit
more aggressive about asking for the
feedback, but you're in the right
context. You're not bothering the user
before that. So, for us, one example of
this is once an agent finished running,
even if it was just a test run, we show
a feedback call to action at the bottom,
right? Did this run do what you
expected? Give us the feedback now. Um,
and this small change actually gave us
like a really nice bump in feedback
submissions surprisingly. So, thumbs up
and thumbs down are a good benchmark, a
good baseline, but try to find these
critical moments in your users's journey
where they'll be most likely to provide
you that feedback either because they're
happy and satisfied or because they're
angry and they want to tell you about
it. Um, even if you work really hard for
the feedback, explicit feedback is still
really rare. Uh, and explicit feedback
that's detailed and actionable is even
harder because people are just not that
interested in providing feedback
generally.
So, you also want to mine user
interaction for implicit feedback. And
the good news is there's actually a lot
of lowhanging fruit possibilities here.
Here's an example from our from our app.
Users can test an agent before they turn
it on to see if everything's going okay.
So, if they do turn it on, that's
actually really strong positive implicit
feedback, right?
Copying a model's response is also good
implicit feedback. Even uh OpenAI is
doing this for chat GPT.
And you can also look for implicit
signals in the conversation. Here the
user is clearly letting us know that
they're not happy with the results.
Here are telling the agent to stop
slinging around which is clearly
implicit negative feedback. I think
sometimes the user sends a follow-up
message that is mostly rehashing what
they asked the previous time to see if
LM interprets that phrasing better.
That's also also good implicit negative
feedback. And there's also a surprising
amount of of cursing.
Uh recently we had a lot of success as
well using an LLM to detect and group
frustrations and we have this weekly
report that we post in our Slack. But it
took us a lot of tinkering to make sure
that LLM understood what frustration
means in the context of our products.
So, I encourage you to try it out, but
expect a lot of tinkering.
You should also not forget to look at
more traditional user metrics, right? Uh
there's a lot of stuff in there for you
to mine implicit signal, too. So, find
what metrics your business cares about
and figure out how to track them. Then,
you can distill some signal from that
data. You can look for customers, for
example, that turned in the last seven
days and go look at their last
interaction with your product before
they left and you're likely to find some
signal there.
Okay. So I have raw data but now I'll
let the indust I'll let the industry
experts speak.
Why is it starting?
Yeah. Or the beating should continue
until everyone looks at their data.
Um okay, but how actually you're going
to do that. So um we believe that the
first step is to either buy or build LM
ops software. We do both. Um, you're
definitely going to need that to
understand your agent runs because one
agent run is probably multiple LM calls,
multiple database interactions, tool
calls, rest calls, whatever. Each one of
them can be source of failure and it's
really important to piece together this
whole story, understand this, you know,
what caused this cascading failure. Um
yeah, I said we are doing both because I
believe vip coding your own internal
tooling is really really easy right now
with cursor and cloud cod and it's going
to pay you massive dividends in the
future um for two reasons. First of all,
it gives you an ability to understand
your data in your own specific domain
context. Uh and the second of all it
also you should be also able to create a
functionality to turn every single
interacting case or every failure into
an eval with the minimal amount of um
fraction. So whenever you see something
interesting there should be like a one
click to turn it into an eval. It should
become your instinct.
Once you understand what's going on on a
singular run basis you can start
understanding things at scale. So now
you can do feedback aggregations,
clustering, you can bucket your uh your
failure modes, you can bucket your
interactions and then you're going to
starting to see what kind of tools are
failing the most. What kind of
interactions are the most problematic
that's going to almost create for you
like a automatic road map. So you'll
know where to apply your time and effort
to improve your product the most. Um
doing anything else is going to be a
suboptimal strategy. Something that we
are also experimenting with is using
reasoning models to explain the
failures. Turns out that if you give
them the trace output, input
instructions and anything you can find,
they are pretty good at finding the root
cause of a failure. Um, even if they are
not going to do that, they're probably
going to explain you the whole run or
just direct your attention into
something that's really interesting and
might help you find the root cause of
the problem.
Cool. So now you have a good short list
of failure modes you want to work on
first. It's time to start building out
your evals.
And we realized over time that there are
different types of evals and the types
of evals that we want to build can be
placed into this hierarchy that
resembles the testing pyramid for those
of you that know that. Um so with unit
test like evals at the base end to end
evals or trajectory evals how we like to
call them in the middle and the ultimate
way of evaluating using AB testing with
stage rolls at rollouts at the top. So
let's talk a bit about those. Starting
with unit test eels, we're just trying
to predict the n plus1 state from the
current state. So these work great when
you want to do simple assertions, right?
For instance, you could check whether
the next state is a specific tool call
or if the two call parameters are
correct or if the answer contains a
specific keyword or if the agent
determined that it was done, all that
good stuff. So if you're starting out,
we recommend focusing on unit test evos
first because these are the easiest to
add. It helps you build that muscle of
looking at your data, spotting problems,
creating evals that reproduce them, and
then just focusing on fixing them,
right? Beware though of like turning
every positive feedback into an eval. We
found that unit test evos are best for
hill climbing specific failure modes
that you spot in your data.
So now unit test evals are not perfect
and we realized that ourselves. uh we
realized we had overindexed on unit test
evos when the new models were coming out
that were objectively stronger models
but we were they were still performing
worse in our internal benchmarks which
was weird
um and because the majority of our evals
were so fine grain this made it really
hard to see the forest for the trees
when benchmarking new new models there
was always a lot of noise when we try
comparing runs like when you're looking
at a single trace it's it's easy to kind
of go through the trace and understand
what's happening but when you need to
kind of look at it from I don't know how
to play it again when you want to look
at it uh through an aggregation of many
traces then it starts getting difficult
to understand what's happening why are
so many of these passing and some of
these are regressing yeah so we realized
that uh maybe machine can help us it
turns out in that previous previous
video when I was investigating uh one
experiment inside brain trust there's a
lot of looking at that screen trying to
figure out what went wrong and we were
like hey maybe we can like just give
this old data to once again a reasoning
LLM and compare the models For us, it
turns out that with brain trust MCP and
reasoning model, you can just ask it to,
hey, look at this run, look at this run
and tell me what's actually different
about the new model that we are going to
deploy. In this case, it was Gemini Pro
versus Claude. And what the reasoning
model found was actually really, really
good. It found that cloud is like a
decisive exeutor, whereas Gemini is
really yapping a lot. It's asking
follow-up questions. It needs some
positive affirmations, and it's
sometimes even hallucinating. uh bad
JSON structures. So yeah, it helped us a
lot. It also surfaces a problem with
unit test evals a lot which is um
different models have different ways of
trying to achieve the same goal and unit
test evals are penalizing different
paths. They're like hardcoded to only
follow follow one path and yeah our unit
test evals were overfitting to our
existing models or actually data
collecting using that model. So what we
started experimenting with is trajectory
evals. Um yeah instead of grading just
one iteration of an agent, we let the
agent run till the whole uh till the to
the end state and we are not grading
just the end state but we are also
grading all the tool calls that were
made along the way and uh all the
artifacts that have been generated along
the way. Um this can be also paired with
LM as a judge. Ver is going to speak
about it later.
Um yeah, but they are not free. I think
they have really high return on
investment, but they are much harder to
set up. Um especially if you are
evaluating runs that have tools that
cause side effects, right? When you are
running an evil, you definitely don't
want to send a email on behalf of the
customer once again, right? Um so we had
a fundamental question whether we should
de mock environment or not. And we
decided that we are not going mock we
are not going to mock the environment
because otherwise you're going to get
data that is just not reflecting the
reality. So what we started doing is
just mirroring uh users environment and
crafting a synthesis uh synthetic copy
of that. Uh also they are much slower
right so they can sometimes take like up
to an hour. Um so it's not pretty great.
And we're also learning a bit more into
LM as a judge. Uh this is when you use
an LLM to grade or compare results from
your EVOS and it's tempting to lean into
them for everything, but you need to
make sure that the judge is judging
things correctly, which can be
surprisingly hard. Uh and you also have
to be careful not to introduce subtle
biases, right? Because even small things
that you might overlook might end up
influencing it.
Lately, we've also been experimenting
with this concept of rubrics based
scoring. We use an LLM to judge the run,
but each row in our data set has a
different set of rubrics, rubrics that
were handcrafted by a human and describe
in natural language what specifically
about this run should the LM be paying
attention to for the score. Uh so one
example of this, did the agent react to
an unexpected error from the calendar
API and then try it again.
So to sum it up, here's our current
mental model of the types of evals that
we built for Zapper agents. We use LM as
a judge or rubrics based evals to build
a highle overview of your systems
capabilities and these are great for
benchmarking new models. We use
trajectory evoss to capture multi-turn
criteria and we use unit test like EVs
to debug specific failures. Uh he'll
climb them. Uh but beware of overfitting
with these.
Yeah. And a couple of closing thoughts.
Don't obsess over metrics. Uh remember
that when a good metrics become a
target, it ceases to be a good target.
Uh so when you're close to achieving
100% score on your evil data set, it's
not meaning that you're doing good job.
Actually meaning that your data set is
just not interesting, right? Because we
don't have AGI yet. So it's probably not
true that your model is that good. Um
something that we're experimenting with
lately is dividing the data set into two
pools. uh into the regressions data set
to make sure that we are making any
changes. We are not breaking existing
use cases for the customers and also the
aspirational data set of things that are
extremely hard. For instance, like
nailing 200 tool calls uh in a row. And
lastly, um let's take a step back.
What's the point of creating evils in
the first place? Uh your goal isn't to
maximize some imaginary number in a
lab-like setting. Uh your end goal is
user satisfaction. So the ultimate judge
um are your users. You shouldn't be
optimizing for the biggest scores for
the evos and completely disregard the
vibes. So that's why you think the
ultimate verification method is an AB
test. Just take a small proportion of
your portion of your traffic, let's say
5% and route it to the new model, root
it to the new prompt, monitor the
feedback, check your metrics like
activation, user retention and so on.
Based on that probably you can make the
most educated guess uh instead of being
in the lab and optimizing this imaginary
number.
That's all. Thank you.
[Music]